today on our show we got jobs
that's right man me and Marc are working
on TV shows where you tell you all about
it today on fat man up hey this is
something we do for fun more than profit
shits and giggles yeah this is a good
time and talking about the [ __ ] we love
and stuff like that but in our day jobs
we like to create this kind of [ __ ] like
you can't be a fan of this kind of [ __ ]
without wanting to do some of it
yourself Wow somebody remember recognize
his true talent when they see it and we
went and got ourselves jobs job' jobs
let's talk about marks got exciting news
and has had it for a while but he had to
sit on it so I've known for a bit tell
him what it's called well I left the LA
Times I think we might have even hinted
at that but you're the only times but I
couldn't say where I was going
where's your land uh I let you landed in
a little town called Castle Rock Castle
Rock Maine my yes my shovel that we
would have spoken about on this show at
some point we would be like there's a
[ __ ] show said in the Stephen King
universe called Castle Rock Wow that
madness like the idea is that oh yeah
dude mansplain your own people tell them
what happens the idea at least is put
forth in the in the in the trailer the
dropped about a month ago I want to say
yeah I want to do sous vide oh yeah the
show Castle Rock is set in the fictional
town that Stephen King created that is
the sort of Nexus and homing beacon for
all of the horrible things that happen
in this giving the Stephen King world
give me a single give him a single what
the [ __ ] whose [ __ ] do I got a shock to
see this whose [ __ ] do I have to shine
you have to do this thank you very much
- sure sure
that's right you have to suck JJ Abrams
his [ __ ] JJ this is a JJ project this is
a bad robot joint JJ is executive
producing it is a joy yeah Stephen King
is sort of overseeing all of it in a way
so it's a king thing it's a king thing
and then the two guys who were running
the show on the ground are Sam Shaw and
Dustin Thomason who had done Manhattan
for wgn-tv show about the people that
make the bomb indeed people make the
bomb let me tell you something
when he first said what this thing was I
was like wow this is this is Avengers
izing or view askew niversity as we say
my gyro your [ __ ] Stephen King
universe that means that [ __ ] Danny
from the shining could run into
Pennywise the clown
if theoretically I mean there's there
are certain books that we have the
certain rights to and we don't but
Danny's first car could be Christine
what and then he hits a dog named Cujo
and he's got a cat's eye well yes so we
the room opened up the writers room up
and DAPA bad the four weeks ago so many
people tell me I keep on writers room
there's about nine of us ten of us like
some some episodes ten episodes are
straight to series on Hulu nine people
to make ten episode little television
guys are gonna be very covered there's
gonna be you'll get your own script you
think I'm hoping so where you all at
least go with some I think I'll go with
somebody I mean the assignments have not
been handed out yet but we've been deep
in the breaking of story through July
middle of July really and then what and
then it's all resumed bleah then they go
into production right like that the plan
is we're gonna write all ten and then
they're gonna go off and shoot all ten
and I don't know where that's gonna
happen yet but yeah for those that don't
follow very closely the production of
television and other media
when you do like a show like oh say
Supergirl which I just directed against
Lee and it airs this week oh that show
they shoot 23 of those episodes per year
their make their writing them write like
a week before their shooting maybe 2
weeks for the shooting so they're
writing them they're always playing
catch-up mm-hmm what they're gonna do a
Mark show sounds like what they call
block shoot indeed yeah shoot the whole
[ __ ] thing like a motion picture this
makes sense when you have a [ __ ]
limited series eight to ten episodes or
as they do with the Netflix Marvel
series a month you shoot the whole you
board the whole [ __ ] and shoot it at
once yeah like so that way you can write
everything at once you can that thing
with you always doing TV like man I wish
we'd have established that thing back in
episode 2 that'll pay off in episode 12
we can do that now without playing
catcher right without having to go back
and just before they single frame is
shot every script will have been written
right that's not the case with most
televisions certainly wasn't that worked
out
you're always like two days ahead of the
production train barreling down line why
can't they just like stockpile up stones
I mean I think that some of it is just
time like if it takes you 40 weeks to
shoot 22 episodes of TV you can like
that and there's always like we're
building in like three weeks four weeks
of writing time just to get ahead if we
got six scripts in the bank before we
start shooting there's always delays
there's always things that go awry
there's always a script that gets blown
up by the network there's always
something that just doesn't gel the way
you want it to and that's when the
production trains us to catch up and
that's when you're like all right we're
in pre-production on Episode we'd have a
script for so we're pretty sure there's
a factory not a bunch of Canadians I
just directed these he's listening named
Robin not just directed the season
finale of the Goldbergs
mmm and our prep week there was no
script to prep yeah because they were
working on like the previous episode and
also this pilot they were shooting and
stuff like that so when we got to the
opening of shoot the shoot week like on
the Monday we had a couple scenes to
shoot but still no full
so that's how they're always trying to
play catch-up and stuff but block
shooting it like this like the Netflix
show like stranger things they didn't
shoot like that you're right they had
all their scripts and then went off and
shot every may allows you to plot better
and stuff
I was economically smart I heard this
this story about David Milch on the
Deadwood yeah a writers room where he he
would he would write every scene the day
they were shooting it and they shot out
of order like they built that town up in
like Santa Clarita somewhere so the
writers room was across the street from
the town so it's where we're shooting
today we're shooting in the bar okay
we're gonna need a bar scene in 104 so
here's that scene and he was just
literally like right the scene they had
to shoot on the stage that day that
would be used six episodes later he's
writing out of sequence so they're
shooting out of sequence and then it
would put it all together in his brain
Wow bad parts in president that's [ __ ]
the rest of it sounds like a [ __ ]
nightmare yes I mean for everybody else
involved yeah yes that is not the way
most shows are done
no because that's nuts Castle Rock will
be on Hulu there's a trailer they could
see online yep you can go on I know they
haven't shot a frame of film it's just a
booty yes it's one of those like he used
it it's a tone trailer it's kind of what
its gonna feel like if everything in the
show were words and I map yeah right
what if they're the stars with words
well that's awesome dude yeah thank you
and you have some news too much he had a
cool job any [ __ ] training it up for
a cooler job you know it's a poor
trajectory as far as employment goes I
want to be independently wealthy I'm not
there yet his name is Elmer J Fudd
[Laughter]
I too have some television news Tom
Abbott over here sadly not any news
about buckaroo banzai yet although
that's not completely dead they're still
just he'll talk and stuff like that but
in the meantime I had met with
these folks at BBC America about
buckaroo banzai back in the day came
down to BBC America on Amazon Amazon got
it but the folks at BBC America like
called me over the office one day I'd be
like do you know Sam twitch I'm like oh
my god from spawn absolutely they're
like we have Sam and twitch like you
want to do you can you do anything with
it is did yes yeah yeah take on it and
you know I'm like well I mean I read the
books when I was a kid when I hid in the
nineties and stuff I know Todd's world a
little bit and Todd McFarlane his name
dropped our boy toy todd todd mcfarlane
you know i was like is it connected to
spawn they're like now it's standalone
but we deal directly with Todd so you
know it could include the rest so I came
up with the take and they liked it
before I knew it BAM we were making a
deal so I I just finished the first
draft of the pilot mmm two pages I have
my notes call on Thursday with BBC with
the folks at BBC I put up a tweet where
I was like I described it as it feels
the tone of it feels like the song
swamped by Talking Heads mm-hmm
so if you know that song that's kind of
what it feels like it's it's funny dark
you know what it's like it's kind of
like if red state and tusk [ __ ] and
nice I've had a baby that was kind of
like Rusk yeah it's very rusty business
it is I love it though I'm kind of like
into it my wife my wife was real excited
because she was like oh my god you wrote
a cop show and I was like wow yeah but
like there's monsters yeah it's more
about to me it's a [ __ ] minute minute
minute is this show about [ __ ] hell
[ __ ] the hell show that's what when I
read it I go oh this is like this is
weird but I go oh I bet you like this
feels like Dogma but reverse like it's
not about angels and
it's about so III think it'd be dope man
I think be really awesome cool if there
if it you know sounds they're into it
like the the person that runs BBC
America did some interview and I was
talking about like we're developing the
salmon Swiss shell with Kevin Smith and
generally they don't [ __ ] talk about
[ __ ] they're developing right they just
drop it
yeah yeah well I mean you don't want to
talk about some you're developing in
case they're like you know development
means we haven't seen anything yet
mmm and so I could have handed in
something were they like what the [ __ ]
but they seem like again it was their
thing like they had the property and
they're like can you do something with
it and and they liked what I suggested
and then they brought me on and just
seems like they're inclined you know to
move forward I don't know for a fact but
I mean it seems like it's better than me
going in there going oh it's a show
about a guy there's a guy into a walrus
and they're like wow Kevin show is
interesting but it would be Kevin show
this is our show and really their show
right like so I feel like feel like it
could go sleep and if it does they'll be
[ __ ] amazing like we would shoot up
in up north in the Pacific Northwest and
the bad man where I've directed two
episodes of Flash there's my flash
directing dick hmm and two episodes of
Supergirl is my Supergirl directing dick
so I've worked with the crews up there i
cherry-pick those crews shouldn't the
flash directing dick be like vibrating
really fast it does and the Supergirl
you should be like hovering that's what
all the ladies love the flash day only
the really curious women go for the
levitating you know what this fell apart
but it did but it was fun my laughs it
was pretty good my but my point is like
I've been now I look at those CW gigs is
like Oh what great training for going to
do this thing so fingers crossed and
it's cool it's it's I don't know it's it
feels like again reverse dogma just as
much as dog knows about angels and
Catholic Christian mythology and
Catholicism this is about the
opposite of all that [ __ ] and it's so
like I don't know like you know most
people like he's spoken to maturity just
like a child [ __ ] dick and he's an
[ __ ] fat jerk of all the [ __ ] they
say is absolutely [ __ ] trick and and
they're absolutely true on the point
where the like he's so immature and
stuff I I learned a long time ago at
least this is my take on life like it
only goes in one direction we get older
and then we [ __ ] die and I've met a
lot of old people and I grew up around
them and I watch them [ __ ] die and
you know look I understand we all got to
die but we don't ever have to get old no
know what I'm saying you have to age
can't get around that you don't have to
get old so to speak and you know this
show [ __ ] appeals to the 18 year old
is me where I'm like are you [ __ ] me
we're writing about the bulges in hell
oh my god we're gonna do a show like I'd
watch that shows clicking around last
night looking for something and I
realize oh you're looking for the show
that you're wanna make it doesn't exist
yet yeah but soon hopefully do they have
a timetable they the way they do their
process or process if you're in Canada
is a BBC America as part of the AMC
networks which also works in my favor
because I know the folks that AMC
networks I've been in business them for
a few seasons no long-standing relations
we do so in any event BBC I think it's
July or August they make their decisions
on the next season it shows so you know
between now and July probably now in
June only a couple months in March right
couple for the next two months I'll do a
couple drafts write the Bible of the
back seven episodes because their first
seasons are eight episodes I think and
then the second seasons are 10 so we I'd
come up with here's what the back seven
looks like and tell the whole story of
the first season and hand in that script
and that Bible and they make a decision
based on that
well first BBC who says we want to move
forward and then they kick it upstairs
then AMC networks has to decide if they
want to move forward nice thing is if
they decide to move forward you're
shooting it it's not just like let's
shoot a pilot and see what happens you
shoot all there you go
right yeah so that'd be cool so the idea
was last year when I was working on the
flash they were wrapping up their season
and a lot of the crew were gonna go work
on Dirk Gently which is a BBC America
shell that's shot up in Vancouver so
they they got cherry pick the the crew
and stuff
that's what same thing we'd go in kind
of the same slot and same idea I'd go
like who can you want to come work on
this show work on the show so once
they're done with their gigs on the CW
like I ain't trying to steal anybody
away while they're working as a good
gigs but when they're done if they're
like ah you know like I could go on
summer vacation or I can [ __ ] hang
out with cab and make a few bucks I
could shoot a cool show right for 10
weeks 12 weeks make a little more
scratch before they go back to work like
you know fingers crossed that not sure I
should be so [ __ ] you know lucky that
that's my problem
yeah so the first of many steps on the
way to production possible production
but I gotta say right now it feels
pretty positive sweet he's in flat-out
production I'm on the way to he's
[ __ ] there the air man but I mean
just knowing how long these things take
you know talking to the guys who like ya
know we've been working on this for
about a year before we opened a room you
know like there's iterations and
versions and pitches and documents and
I'm not saying like Oh give it up for
these heroes but like it takes a while
it takes a lot to keep your passion
going for ya so I'm saying like think
about the moment of inspiration like oh
I want to do this and then like let's
say six months later you know it's still
like what are we doing yeah I want to do
this this is great I love it but you
know hope wanes the longer time goes on
but then to suddenly a year later I mean
writers room open hope springs eternal
yeah okay so yeah are you good Brad's
good things happening for both these
guys yeah look at us look at it good
guys
nice guys finish here we are born to be
kings we are princes here we belong
fighting for survival
these powers that [ __ ] sounds like Sam
twitch I guess it's pretty recognizable
[ __ ] you stole the Highlander song gives
us what's more metal than that man
like what's more metal than Queen no
again jethro tull
that was a big in any event I should I
wish that's gonna be a problem
where I'm like oh I want to use the
Queen so we should be so lucky we get
this drop some loot to get that song
please fingers crossed
also Killer Queen there it is folks
Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith and
I'm Bernard tune in next episode we'll
talk about other people's [ __ ] we won't
[ __ ] rub our good fortune in your
face yes we'll talk about other people's
good fortune no slapping dicks in
anybody's faces no we're gonna put our
dicks away now go back to being
pop-culture commentators commentators
you love to mash see you next time
same bat-time same bat-channel spawn
cast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]